little practice
oh fish
piece of cake that's what i wasn't
trying to do
i was trying not to pot the ball
the butterfly effect really is used as a
paradigm of chaos the idea that perhaps
a butterfly flapping its wings in july
in new york can determine whether or not
it snows in nottingham in december so
that tiny tiny change amplifies through
the weather systems it's an overstated
example that's for sure i mean in
reality it would make no difference
because all of the other perturbations
the wind the waves the ripples
aeroplanes coming across would be far
more significant but the concept that
some systems are so sensitive is to be
essentially unpredictable
is very real and the interesting thing
there is that really simple systems show
this many simple systems show this
behavior when i hit the the reds with
this cue ball now i may not be good
enough to actually hit them but the
point i want to make here is the
configuration of the reds after i hit
them with a cue ball is in a sense a
demonstration of celtic motion
well that wasn't very good that was a
pretty boring thing to do
you see the reason i've tempted you down
here to do this is for once we get you
on camera
and we guys can have a good laugh at you
rather than the other way around
so what this is is a system it's a
double pendulum the idea is to show that
even a really simple system like a
pendulum that's so regular of course
it's been used to make clocks for 100
years or so if you take two of them and
couple them together and give them
enough energy those pendulums can lose
completely their regular behavior and
behave completely erratically
chaotically uh brady what i want you to
try to do using your semi-professional
skills as a snooker player is to hit the
front
the front ball there oh yeah sure i've
forgotten i'm the cameraman
okay yeah okay go wait a minute i'll
move it i'm waiting for it now
go
oh that's much better now look at that
configuration we'll try to remember
where all these
balls have gone in particular let's look
at them up at that far end of the table
there now go on brady put them all back
again and we'll compare the positions
i'll pay you a hundred pounds if you can
repeat that condition no i pay you a
million pounds if you can repeat that
condition
yep
good well done
so hit that front ball again as close as
you can to the previous position with
the same speed and then just look let's
just look at the conditions this time
okay fire
there you are you see the condition is
completely different and up there you
potted the bread yeah you potted the red
up there which you didn't do before so i
saved my million pounds you see here's
one pendulum of course very predictable
very regular
if we set the thing in motion with quite
a low energy so we lift them uh slowly
you can see that's also quite regular
the two
arms are kind of vibrating against one
another all the time if i lift that
right up in the air and then let it go
you can see the system's moving like
crazy
oh there it's got a load of energy units
away so you can see that there's a big
uh change of energy between the lower
pendulum and the upper pendulum and it's
meaning that the tips of those penduly
are moving in very different ways and if
you track out the motion of the tips of
those pendulums you'll see that they
fill space pretty much uniformly so
rather than just rocking backwards and
forwards along a single arc they're
flying around in a completely erratic
way so just the very fact of having two
of these penduly coupled together two
different pivot points changes
completely the long-term behaviour of
that system even any tiny change away
from those initial conditions will
eventually produce completely
uncorrelated behavior in fact if you if
you do this with a computer simulation
you set the two of them off and perhaps
change
the start speed by one part and say 10
million after only three or four swings
the motion's completely separate so that
that kind of sensitivity to initial
condition really shows through quite
quickly but if the computer simulation
can crunch at when you put the initial
conditions in it's not chaotic is it
though it's just different conditions
produced differently that's right that's
right so the laws that determine how
these things move are really simple
essentially f equals m a just newton's
second law so what's going into that the
math is really simple
however
the
trajectories that that produces depends
so sensitively to how you set it in
motion that the overall picture is very
very messy and very chaotic looking
that's a demonstration of the
sensitivity
of this problem this is a many-body
problem lots of billion balls here it's
the sensitivity of the initial
conditions if you just deviate the point
at which you hit that front read by a
little bit or just change the
speed at which is hitting you get a
totally different configuration
it's become a very complex problem
professor can i ask you this though
you said it's very complex but if i gave
you enough parameters and enough
computing power great great question now
this relates us on to on really brings
us on to the question of things like
like the weather and you're right if we
could precisely locate all the positions
the reds are
inside the triangle we take the triangle
off of course and then locate the
starting position of your ball and the
direction which is going and the speed
with it with which it's going and find
out exactly where it hits that front
ball
then in principle we could do a pretty
good job of predicting the motions but
we find that
just
we can only specify those things to so
many significant figures those numbers
to so many significant figures and if
you start changing those significant
figures by a small amount the effect the
change in the pattern is amplified very
very strongly and of course this is very
similar to the problem predicting the
weather you can put predicting you know
the velocities all the wind wind
patterns say in the atlantic and the
pressures and so on uh to a reasonable
degree of accuracy to say a couple of
percent and that's great for doing
weather forecasting for a couple of days
uh or maybe maybe a week if you're lucky
but uh trying to predict the weather six
months from now or even one month month
from now is much much more tricky and a
similar thing is operating for these
these balls very very sensitive to how
you hit that front ball usually in a
chaotic system you can write down very
simply the equations of motion so you
really understand the physics you
understand the forces that are setting
the system in motion you understand how
to write down newton's laws or
alternative formalisms to newton's laws
that tell you how the system will will
evolve so you understand that
but the problem is that if those
laws are
such that the system's got
several ways in which it can move so in
this case there's two ways in which the
system can can move we've got the
displacement of that pendulum the
displacement of that pendulum if the the
number of things that's keeping that
system constrained is equal to the
number of motions it can have then it
behaves regularly but if you start to
take constraints away from the system
then that allows the thing to evolve in
a chaotic way so so
all it is is in terms of whether a
system's chaotic or not is
is it free to become chaotic if it is it
will do the key point about playing
snooker of course is that
there's friction this ball will not go
on forever so i want to make the very
drastic assumption that we're going to
neglect friction so i want you to
imagine this ball rather than slowing
down just has no dissipation it can just
carry on forever without losing
momentum so let's try this
now the other key feature with this as
you see is
that uh the ball bounces
not quite but more or less with specular
reflection speculum means it behaves
like light hitting and reflecting off a
mirror where the angle of incidence
is equal to the angle of reflection
because the sides of the table these two
sides are parallel and these two sides
are parallel we've got a rectangle here
it means that the motion that we have
when we let this frictionless ball go
the
motion is not chaotic it's regular so
before i describe what a chaotic stadium
is first of all i want to show you what
a regular stadium is so let's do it
again we hit this thing really really
hard and we've got our specular
reflection
and this thing would carry on going and
we can write down a very simple equation
to describe that motion so this this is
something that has been sitting in my
dad's shed for two three years and we
used to move the children with it it's a
sprinkler for the garden so you put your
hose on the bottom and it squirts up
here it squirts through this flowing
thing and what happens is it flies
around all over the place and flicks
watering so you see a few bits coming
out of it so it flicks water all over
and rather than a circular sprinkler
just watering part of your lawn or part
of your flower bed this flicks water all
over the place so everything gets
completely soaked but the principle of
it is really the same as this double
pendulum it's another double pendulum
system because we've got one pivot here
for this tube another one here for the
flower head and so the motion's really
the same as this double pendulum and the
fact that the two of them can flick
around all over and spray water around
all over the place means that you can
very easily and efficiently water your
garden
if you really want to get something
random just take two very simple systems
and let them talk to one another let
them communicate with one another by
this pipe and that's perhaps the strange
thing that that
it it really is that taking to suit
things that are so simple about as
simple as you could make it and letting
them interact produces something that's
unpredictable but in this case
useful and well quite pretty i guess we
can start up our ball here and send it
off
and why is this thing so regular well
the ball hits
and
this angle is equal to that angle we're
assuming there's no friction we're
assuming elastic properties it carries
on in a straight line it then bounces in
a very predictable way it comes back
again now here's a stadium the
bonimovich stadium where these rules
don't apply and it's a very easy thing
to construct it's just a couple of
semi-circles
and then two rectangular size
so instead of these flat edges here
and here and parallel edges we keep
these two side ones parallel to each
other but we have curvy bits there now
immediately you see we see that two
interesting types of orbit clearly a
trajectory like that where the ball just
bounces back and forth here is very
boring and also this one
back and forth here
is completely predictable
and i can also devise another type of
motion let me see if i can draw it yeah
i can do this one if i just get that
diamond one right
that
is simple and is completely stable
however there's another class of of
trajectories where things get much more
complicated if i just do some general
trajectory where i start say here
off the mid position
and go around here then
with specular reflection i can do this
following my simple rules and you can
see how this is beginning to look a bit
interesting now uh what's going to
happen i got to do that speculation it's
going to come over here
and then go up there
and there there now what's it going to
do it's going to come back here so if
you start doing this this motion just
goes on on forever it never reproduces
path is far from periodic and in
particular if i just change this
trajectory by a little bit
a little bit then i'll end up very
quickly getting an orbit that's much
much different from the one when i
started off by sending the particle this
way so huge sensitivity to initial
conditions
now
too hard for me